there were no new proposals at this
point from the Greek Minister at the
first step will be that the Greek
government will send the Eurogroup a new
request a new request letter for ESM
support today I called all leaders to
try to find consensus which will be our
common success with no losses or winners
if this doesn't happen it will mean the
end of the negotiations with all the
possible consequences including the
worst case scenario all of us who lose
our inability to find agreement may lead
to the bankruptcy of Greece and the
insolvency of its banking system and for
sure it will be most painful for the
Greek people the Commission is prepared
for everything
we have a grexit scenario prepared in
detail we have a scenario as far as
humanitarian aid is concerned and we
have and that's the scenario I must
prefer a scenario how to deal with the
problem now keeping Greece as a member
of the area the final deadline and this
week all of us are responsible for the
crisis and all of us have a
responsibility to resolve it